nicolas giraud il est porte parole de la
confédération paysanne
mon sort nicolas giraud merci de
répondre à nos questions
demain c'est donc le vote ultime des
eurodéputés dans quel état d'esprit est
ce que vous êtes et dans quel état
d'esprit sont également vos confrères
mais on est on est assez dubitatif par
rapport à la tournure qu'a pu prendre la
politique agricole commune aussi bien au
niveau européen qu'au niveau français
c'est à dire que demain ce sera le
dernier vote au niveau européen mais
c'est pas encore totalement fini c'est à
dire que chaque état doit rédiger son
plan stratégique national commence à
être rédigée par la france et là jusqu'à
la fin de l'année pour l'envoyer à la
commission européenne et nous on attend
deux du gouvernement et du ministre de
normandie qui revoit à la hausse le son
en plan stratégique national parce qu'il
prend pas suffisamment en compte les
enjeux actuels qu'ils soient sociaux
qu'ils soient environnementaux ou qu'ils
soient alimentaires
il ya aussi le côté vert de cette
réforme les ong écologistes jugent que
le texte ne va pas suffisamment loin et
qu'il manque d'ambition quelle est votre
réaction
mais j'allais dire il ya bien ça c'est
une certitude déjà dire y'a pas que les
ong qui mettra en lumière la cour des
comptes très récemment a pointé
l'inefficacité de la pac par rapport aux
enjeux écologiques et biodiversité
l'autorité environnementale qui doute
qui devaient évaluer le plan stratégique
national qui a commencé et écrire et qui
a commencé écrit par le ministère a
relevé
de graves lacunes en termes
d'environnement pour répondre et à la
crise climatique et à la perte de
biodiversité
donc c'est pas seulement des ong au des
paysans qui remettent ça en cause c'est
toute une partie des
personnalités qui regardent la pac de
près le coeur de la réforme c'est de
permettre à chaque état de répartir les
deniers bon qu 1802 sur le territoire
son récent réel contrôle bien loin de
l'esprit du projet est lancé en 62 c'est
ce que a déploré dans une tribune au
monde l'eurodéputé verts yannick jadot
et candidat écologiste à l'élection
présidentielle votre réaction
ma réaction c'est que de toute façon
de gouvernement en gouvernement de
politiques agricoles en politique
agricole commune on s'est beaucoup
éloignés des fondamentaux de la pac qui
était une pac alimentaire au départ est
le fondement de la politique agricole
commune au niveau européen c'est
l'objectif de sécuriser l'alimentation
pour l'ensemble des citoyens européens
c'est aussi l'objectif de sécuriser le
revenu du monde paysan et j'allais dire
sur les deux on est en échec les paysans
sont de moins en moins bien rémunérés un
bon paquet disparaissent en trente ans
on a perdu deux tiers des paysans est la
pac en a une responsabilité énorme et au
niveau alimentation on voit bien que la
crise sanitaire a encore mis en lumière
la précarité alimentaire ne cesse
d'augmenter et
on peut bien se demander en quoi la
politique agricole commune pourrait
mieux répondre à ça et au lieu de
s'atteler à mieux répondre à ces enjeux
sociaux économiques et alimentaires le
ministre de l'agriculture
elle est l ensemble de la commission
européenne nous allons sur le pack de la
stabilité c'est à dire que on va
continuer à voir les mêmes les mêmes
outils la même répartition les mêmes
équilibres qui sont pour nous
complètement déséquilibré pour le coup
alors que presque
d'après ce que j'ai compris avec plus de
paperasse quand même d'après ce que j'ai
compris
ben là la paperasse est toujours le
quotidien j'allais dire du monde paysan
je sais pas si on aura plus haut niveau
au niveau de cette pac là après on peut
pas non plus
demander et j'allais dire à avoir une
des subventions la politique agricole
commune et de l'état français sans avoir
un minimum d'éléments à pouvoir
répondre est justifié après il faut pas
que ça devienne quelque chose
d'absolument et non mais et qui a peur
les le monde paysan au niveau de l'
enveloppe ses 387 milliards d'euros sur
sept ans donc
270 milliards d'êtres directes aux
agriculteurs c'est assez c'est pas assez
pourquoi
au niveau du volume financier j'allais
dire on est pas mal on peut toujours
être mieux mais les différents accords
qui ont été posées au niveau européen on
garantit une stabilisation de l'envelope
2 la politique agricole commune en
france ça à peu près 9 milliards par an
qui arrive sur l'ensemble du monde
agricole c'est c'est globalement stable
mais après l'enjeu c'est surtout comment
est ce qu'on la répartie c'est à dire
que aujourd'hui en france 20% du monde
agricole 20 % des exploitations reçoit
55 % des z donc ça veut dire que c'est
c'est pas bien équilibré il ya toute une
partie du monde agricole notamment les
petites structures des petites fermes kg
skis et ne reçoivent rien ou très peu de
la pac vu que la pac est donnée à la
surface plus on a deux surfaces sur sa
ferme plus aura touché deux subventions
de la politique agricole commune même si
sur sa ferme petites ou grandes on
répond à des enjeux sociaux et des
enjeux environnementaux ou alimentaires
finalement ça s'est beaucoup moins pris
en compte que la surface et comment
l'améliorer parce que le chiffre 20 %
des groupes d'agriculteurs accapare 80 %
des aides directes est ce que ce que
vous avez une proposition
nous clairement ça c'est déjà un petit
peu améliorée en france on est plus à 26
touche 80 on est à 20 qui touche 50 5
essais et c'est pour ça que le ministre
de l'agriculture français se cache là
derrière en disant on fait déjà mieux
que l'ensemble de la commission
européenne va pas encore aller plus loin
nous ça nous semble être une grave
erreur et pour arriver à faire mieux au
niveau social il ya 3 ans mesure toute
simple la première c'est de plafonner
les aides nous à la confédération
paysanne on revendique que au delà de
45000 euros dead par an et par actif
paysans on arrête les subventions ça
c'est la première mesure
la deuxième mesure c'est une aide aux
petites et moyennes fermes c'est à dire
que on est un forfait qui soient
dissociées finalement de la surface pour
les fermes qui sont petit pour arriver à
mieux les soutenir et à donner
l'impulsion pour que plus de paysannes
et paysans plus s'installer et la
troisième mesure c'est une majoration
des aides sur les 52 premier secteur qui
est déjà en place dans la réforme
actuelle mais à un niveau insuffisant
tout ça c'est des mécanismes qui aurait
pu être mis en place dans dans le plan
stratégique national français le cadre
européen elle permettait aujourd'hui le
ministre a choisi de
n'activer aucun de ces leviers la de la
distribution merci nicolas giraud
d'avoir répondu à une question je
rappelle que vous êtes le porte parole
de la confédération paysanne